- FELT VERY CONSTRICTING.
- EVERY DAY WAS FILLED
WITH FEAR AND ANXIETY.
- I JUST WOULD LIKE TO GET UP
TODAY AND LIVE A NORMAL LIFE.
- WHEN I WAS
ON THE SAN DIEGO DIET,
I WAS THIN AND SAD.
BUT TODAY...
[crowd ohs]
I'M INTRODUCING
THE SAN DIEGO MINDSET.
EVERY TIME I GOT SKINNY,
I'D GET DEPRESSED.
I WOULD START TAKING ALL TYPES
OF PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS.
THEY WERE POISONING MY BODY.
BUT THEN I STARTED EATING
THE FOOD I WANTED TO EAT,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
I DIDN'T NEED ANY DRUGS.
[belches]
both: WE'RE GOING
TO SAN DIEGO IN HERE.
- THERE IS NO PAIN,
NO RESTRICTIONS.
- IT'S TIME FOR YOU
TO UNLOCK THE SECRET
THAT GENERATIONS OF PEOPLE
HAVE KNOWN.
EVERY SINGLE PHARAOH
HAD A FAVORITE FOOD,
AND HE WOULD EAT THAT FOOD
WHEN HE HAD TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS.
WHEN ABRAHAM LINCOLN
FREED THE SLAVES
AND MADE THIS COUNTRY EQUAL,
HE ATE A MEAL.
AND NOW WE LIVE
IN THE INTEGRATED SOCIETY
THAT WE BLESS
OUR COUNTRY WITH TODAY.
I'LL TELL YOU ONE THING
THAT THE PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY
AND THE DIET INDUSTRY
WILL NEVER TELL YOU,
IS THAT ALIENS
ARE ALWAYS EATING FOOD.
THEY ARE EATING BIG MEALS
EVERY DAY ON THE SPACESHIPS
THAT THEY'RE FLYING
THROUGH SPACE ON TO GET TO US.
WHY DO YOU THINK THOSE ALIENS
ARE ALWAYS TRYING TO EAT HUMANS?
BECAUSE HUMANS ARE ICE CREAM
TO ALIENS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GONNA
TELL YOU A LOT OF THINGS,
BUT LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING RIGHT NOW, FRIEND.